-Frank Sheeran.
I'm saying that right?
-Yeah, you said it right.
-Uh, under the contract,
management can only
fly or drive around
very specific charges.
So, you every show up late?
-No.
-You have any moving violations?
-Do you drink on the job?
-No.
-You ever hit anybody?
-On the job?
-Yeah.
-I don't think so.
-Alright, then.
We don't have nothing
to worry about.
-I want you to meet my cousin,
Russell Bufalino.
-How are you?
-Hey. Nice to meet you.
-It was like the army.
You followed orders,
you did the right thing.
You got rewarded.
-[ Screams ]
-A friend of ours is having
a little trouble,
a friend at the top.
-Back then, there was nobody
in this country
who didn't know
who Jimmy Hoffa was.
-He's got a gun!
-Get that gun out of his hand!
-You always charge
a guy with a gun.
With a knife, you run away.
So you charge with a gun.
With a knife, you run.
Hiya, Frank. Would you like
to be a part of history?
-Yes, I would.
-Big business and the government
are working together
trying to pull us apart.
-Something's got to be done.
-What else he say?
Now's not the time to not say.
-We're going to war
with these people.
-War.
-Things have gotten out of hand
with our friend.
-You got to sit down.
Everybody says so.
-No, I'm not sitting down.
I can't do it.
-It's what it is.
-What it is.
-I knew things.
They don't know what I know.
♪♪
-It's going to happen.
-Either way, he's going.
♪♪
-You know, I don't, uh, I don't
care whether you did it or not.
That makes no difference to me.
-Yeah, I know.
-I'm here to defend you.
Right?
-Right.
What do you want to know? You
want to know if I did it or not?
-No.
-[ Chuckles ]